i saw uh that you said that back in the
day used to rob all the cameramen in
chicago come on man don't do that
yeah i had my little ups and downs you
know i did my i did my little wrong [ __ ]
i was gonna say like um
did you ever
spin the block on the cameraman where
they ended up working with you later on
because you know there's there's only a
few cameramen i'm sure i mean i don't
know i don't even for real for real i
only remember all the dumb [ __ ] i used
to be on back then when i was on some
shorty [ __ ] but like
i used to be on some goofy [ __ ] like
that but i don't remember exactly all
the ones you know it probably is because
all the cameraman's [ __ ] yeah you
know i am who i am today you know i
overcame all i said so a lot of the
cameraman spoke with me it probably been
one of the years i don't even remember
that so long ago it feels like a
cameraman's probably the easiest lick
right
it's certain
i was really i was it wasn't like i was
doing it for the money i was really
doing it to get my own camera to shoot
my own videos and have my my cameraman
shooting my videos so you would jack the
nice camera yeah give it to your
cameraman and then be like you got new
equipment shoot my [ __ ] on my own that's
not a bad i mean listen that's not bad
at least you weren't like at least there
was a some sort of purpose you were
doing it to further your career
it's for a purpose yeah and ain't never
for no reason 100